vuoi diventare una di noi
che cos'è questo beh potrei dubitare che
cos'è questo rumore
[Musica]
marino sei tu
c'è qualcuno con camera
[Musica]
qui ho passato qualcuno c'è nessuno
no
[Musica]
se qualcuno qua sotto la scrivania non
c'è niente bravo berlino controlla c'è
qualcosa c'è qualcosa
bravo contro un bel berlino
se qualcuno qua
[Musica]
sto aspettando la prossima prova ma la
sfera non parla più non so che cosa devo
fare adesso forse la prova è già
iniziata ma la sfera grande non era
sparita brava ma avete visto anche voi
una presenza strana
lasciate un mi piace se anche voi
l'avete vista cosa sono questi rumori
c'è qualcuno dentro l'armadio migliore
vitale
prima che esca fuori qualcosa da un
armadio tale aiuta no c'è qualcuno qua
guidare tutti finalmente guarda che cosa
aspetta guarda ti guardo c'è una
sorpresa per me dell'armadio anonime non
aprirlo nuovo aprirlo per berlino lo sta
per che ha visto tutto nero berlino che
tu hai visto l'arma che si stava
muovendo si stava muovendo si si stava
muovendo da solo e non c'ha le ruote
questo no le ante dell'armadio vediamo
che cosa c'è tempo
no no no no no può essere pericoloso se
nessuno
strano metodi volta che arrivi tu
mettono le cose paranormali comunque
stavo osservando la sfera ti ricordi che
la sfera grande foste qua qua sopra
no era stato sostituito da quella
piccola fatti ma ora ci sono tutte e due
ok va bene mentre tu cerchi di risolvere
questo mistero io ritorno a cucinare
pensi ad altro
bene ho deciso che mi metterò qua
davanti all'armadio a controllare se
succede qualcosa costa non succede più
niente
forse la presenza si è spostata e non è
più lì dentro l'armadio
se sentite un rumore strano e solo
berlino che il grano chi ha i suoi
giocattoli e berlino quando smetti mai
erano chiare
tantissimi fermato un momento hai
sentito lo fai un po di silenzio
non riesco a sentire i rumori da te
[Musica]
ma tu dici che dovrei controllare perché
no
che cosa faccio non penso che sia una
buona idea aprire l'armadio anche perché
potrebbe spuntare fuori qualsiasi cosa
forse devo prendere la sfera è provare a
ricontattare la fata che buono
non vedo l'ora di mangiarvi tutto da
guida ripeti succede di ho sentito
urlare vita
sanità ei ma sei lassù che ci parla su
file a su radio mi è successo jamila tra
la se qualcosa nell'armadio mi ha
strappato una cosa morta
devi guardare la dentro ok però
preparati prendi qualcosa per catturarlo
ok tu nasconditi ci penso io non ti
preoccupare nasconditi casomai viene a
cercarti di nuovo io non posso
avvicinarmi altrimenti mi strapperò
anche l'altra dai molto ha detto ok non
ti preoccupare adesso ci penso io
nasconditi nasconditi ok ci penso io qui
non guardando qua dietro si si io ti
affermerò d'acqua va bene stai attenta
che cosa posso prendere una penna un
evidenziatore vedere una paletta ma che
ci faccio con la paletta uno specchio la
spaventa 11 specchio l'osso di berlino
sono stati partito in testa
no mi stai portando male tiene corso dai
che cosa possa cercare
idea un righello si vi aiuterò con un
righello ok vediamo non sento niente
[Musica]
chi c'è nell'armadio scivoli 6 maggio